- Hi, everyone. Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
And I just wanted to remind you
that we are a not-for-profit
and we can only exist
through donations from
folks like yourself.
Our goal is for everyone
to reach their potential.
Potential is everywhere.
Unfortunately, access is not.
And that's what Khan
Academy exists to change.
We are trying to reach tens
of millions of students
around the world, students in historically
under-resourced communities,
working with school districts in the US,
working with stakeholders
from around the planet
to make sure that students have
a way to fill in their gaps,
learn at their own time and pace,
have access to truly
rigorous course materials.
So I encourage you to think
about supporting Khan Academy.
The social return on
investment on Khan Academy,
we're about the budget
of a large high school
but we reach already a chunk of humanity
and we wanna reach many, many more,
with over 140 million
registered users today
and hopefully billions going forward.
So please think about making a donation.
If you've benefited from Khan Academy,
you know from folks who've
benefited from Khan Academy,
or, maybe most importantly,
if you wanna see tens to
hundreds of millions to billions
of other students benefit
from these resources,
please think about making a donation.
Thank you.
(chimes trill)